On a dark night twelve years ago, somewhere
in the East Blue, a young kid is trapped in
a cage on a ship that is sailing away from
his home island.
He is shouting and swinging his fists at anyone
in reach, but the crew is too strong to care.
Then a figure in a long, green cloak walks
up, kneels in front of the child and pulls
back his hood.
The furious child launches a punch, but the
man with the mysterious tattoo easily blocks
it, and pulls the child tight against the
bars.
“Where are you taking me?”
the child screams.
And all the mysterious man says is “your
new home”.
This child is Monkey D. Luffy.
And the man?
He is the most wanted man in the world, and
the child’s father, Monkey D. dragon.
Which means that even though Luffy would probably
fight and scream the entire voyage, in this
what if scenario there is literally nothing
he can do to stop his father from taking him
to the Revolutionary Army base to raise him
as a Revolutionary.
And wow, this is absolutely going to COMPLETELY
change Luffy’s life in SO MANY ways.
Some of which are bad, and surprisingly some
that are incredibly awesome.
First though, Luffy would care one bit that
Dragon is his father.
I mean, when he originally learned about his
father he didn’t care at all, and I think
the same would apply here.
But once they get back to the revolutionary
army’s base, I think Luffy’s attitude
will eventually start to change.
Because at this point, Dragon’s group of
freedom fighters is FULL of people that Luffy
became friends with later on anyway, like
this huge cyborg guy who saved Luffy at the
end of Sabaody.
Plus Ivankov, who literally saved Luffy’s
life during the prison break before the war
at Marineford.
So knowing Luffy he will start to make friends
and be happy here pretty quickly because if
you remember from his flashback, Luffy truly
just wanted some friends to hang out with
all along.
So maybe coming to his father’s base might
be a good thing.
I mean, he’ll definitely find some better
mentors than a band of mountain bandits.
That’s just the start though because you
WILL NOT BELIEVE how much stronger Revolutionary
Luffy is going to become.
First of all, we can assume that Dragon knows
haki, so he’d probably teach Luffy the basics
as he grew up.
So add Armament and Observation haki to Luffy’s
arsenal.
Plus, there are also other characters with
devil fruits at the Revolutionary's base,
so they might help Luffy master his powers
even faster since he really didn’t know
anyone with a devil fruit back on his home
island.
On top of that, there are other fighting styles
Luffy could learn.
For example, this revolutionary fishman is
a master of fishman karate, which is used
by the fishmen to control water, but is also
an extrememly strong martial arts form.
There is also Ivankavo’s Newkama kempo,
which Sanji mastered during the time skip.
So yeah, this version of Luffy is going to
have way more training and fighting techniques
than he did originally.
Things are about to get even more crazy though
because when Luffy was eight years old, there
was ANOTHER super important child that Dragon
rescued and brought to the revolutionary base.
Of course I’m talking about Sabo, who originally
grew up with Luffy and Ace in the forests
of their home island.
However, once he learned just how awful the
rulers of the kingdom were, he decided to
flee the kingdom to start a life at sea.
Unfortunately, he was quickly sunk by a world
noble, and was rescued by Dragon and then
raised as a Revolutionary.
So add an ally to the party because Luffy
is now going to have a new best friend.
And wow, can you just imagine the fun AND
trouble these two would get into running around
the Revolutionary Army base?
They might even destroy the entire thing if
we’re being honest, but not only that they’d
also have a super important role to play in
each other’s lives.
You see, after Sabo was blown up he lost his
memories and completely forgot his life at
the Goa kingdom.
However, that’s all going to change because
I can just imagine when Luffy mentions he
was from the Goa kingdom Sabo most likely
would regain those memories that he had lost.
And although that wouldn’t include his time
growing up with Luffy because that didn’t
happen in this scenario, Sabo would remember
Ace, which is going to play a very important
role in just a minute.
In fact, once he regains his memories Sabo
might desperately want to go back to the Goa
kingdom or at least send a message to let
Ace know he is still alive.
And they might even try to convince Ace to
join the Revolutionaries, but for now we are
going to leave Ace to follow his normal path
to becoming a pirate.
Now at this point you might be wondering why
Dragon wanted to bring Luffy here in the first
place.
And while there could be many reasons, the
one that makes the most sense to me is that
Dragon might know the true secrets of Luffy’s
devil fruit awakening.
So when he learns that he son has eaten these
powers, then he will want to raise Luffy himself
to give him the best opportunity to one day
awaken Gear 5, which is actually the perfect
power for a revolutionary freedom fighter.
Back to child Luffy though, perhaps the most
GAME-CHANGING thing about Luffy growing up
with the Revolutionaries is that there is
NO WAY that Dragon can keep them on the island
forever.
So eventually these two would be taken out
on missions all over the world.
And during this time both of the boys and
this revolutionary girl will learn so much
about the world.
I mean originally Luffy had literally ZERO
formal education but now he would likely learn
about different kingdoms, races, and probably
even really practical stuff like how to sail
a ship.
Which we all know he never learned that skill.
On top of all that, they would learn about
the world government’s oppression and dark
secrets, along with the Revolutionary Army’s
true goals of taking down the world nobles.
Now you might be thinking that Luffy wouldn’t
really care about that stuff, and normally
you would be right, but I think this version
of Luffy would be exposed to so many suffering
people that he would also develop a belief
that the world nobles are truly evil.
All this would lead to a slightly more mature
version of Luffy.
Although I do have to admit, I just can’t
imagine Luffy ever being the type of person
you would want to take on secret spy missions.
He’s not exactly the sneaky type.
But eventually Luffy, Sabo, and Koala would
probably be given their own missions to recruit
new members or free oppressed kingdoms.
However, Luffy as a Revolutionary is still
going to have a MASSIVE problem.
You see, in this scenario, Luffy still has
his devil fruit, he was still inspired by
Shanks, and he still received the straw hat.
So deep down he still dreams of being a pirate.
So let’s say around age seventeen, Luffy
just one day decides it’s time to follow
that inner dream.
Now Dragon might be furious and even want
to stop him since he knows all the Revolutionary
Army’s secrets, but eventually he’d let
him go.
I mean he already basically approved of Luffy
being a pirate.
And besides Dragon, Sabo would probably be
the most heartbroken because even though Luffy
would probably try to recruit Sabo and Koala
to join him, those two would probably stick
with the Revolutionaries.
Luffy simply can’t set sail on his own though,
at least not in the Grand Line, so let’s
say the Revolutionaries drop him off back
in the East Blue and he starts his journey
like normal.
And while his adventure is going to start
out the same, you’re going to be SHOCKED
at how quickly Revolutionary Luffy’s pirate
adventure is going to end.
But first, I still think he recruits his crewmates
like normal, so hop on board, everyone with
the only main difference in the East Blue
being that Luffy is way stronger since he
knows haki already.
So he would fly through his enemies here,
freeing the villages from the bad guys.
Man, his father would be proud.
And even the man who gave Luffy his first
real defeat would simply be no match for this
Haki and Karate buffed up Luffy.
Which means that most of the pre-timeskip
arcs will continue like normal, although there
are a few super important changes that would
just make too much sense with this more mature
and politically aware Luffy.
For example, in Alabasta Luffy might call
up Sabo and let him know what is going on
with the civil war.
And if the revolutionaries knew about this,
they might even come help stop the people
from destroying each other alongside Luffy
and the crew.
Which would also be THE PERFECT opportunity
for Sabo to reunite with Ace, since Ace was
also briefly present here.
And this means Luffy gets to meet the fiery
brother he never had, which is going to play
a big role in the story later on.
Besides that though, there’s really not
a whole lot that would change during the pre-time
skip arcs.
That is until we reach the government island
Enies Lobby where Luffy and the crew try to
save Robin from these secret agents.
And if we’re keeping up with the idea that
Luffy and Sabo are in frequent contact, then
I can see the Revolutionaries taking advantage
of the chaos on the government island.
Maybe they sneak in and steal some valuable
info or something like that.
So after the Straw Hats rescue Robin, we reach
the first MAJOR MAJOR change during Luffy’s
encounter with the former Revolutionary Kuma
on Thriller Bark.
And since Luffy is already way stronger at
this point, he’d probably have a much easier
time defeating this shadow guy which means
he will be awake for the epic confrontation
at the end of this arc.
Now, I won’t get into heavy manga spoilers
here, but wow, this scene hits way harder
with what we know about Kuma now, and I cannot
even imagine how much it would break Luffy
to see that his friend Kuma has been turned
into a government slave.
But now we have to ask if Kuma would ever
follow through with his orders and actually
try to kill Luffy.
You have to remember that for the purpose
of this video, Luffy grew up with the Revolutionaries
and would definitely have known Kuma.
So the Warlord might just straight up refuse
to kill his former friend, so it’s entirely
possible that we never get the nothing happened
moment.
On top of that, I can say that the most devastating
moments in the entire story would also be
way different.
Because Sabaody is the point in the story
when the straw hats truly learned just how
evil the celestial dragons are, and exactly
how outmatched they were when facing the marine
admirals.
So considering what Luffy now knows about
the world nobles, he might go even further
than just punching this guy and might actually
kill the man.
Which is extreme, I know, but Revolutionary
Luffy is a different man.
But that’s just the first possible change
because we also simply have to reevaluate
what would happen at the end of this arc.
Because before Luffy and the crew did not
trust Kuma at all, so when he came in making
everyone disappear there was mass panic.
But in this scenario Luffy should be able
to figure out that Kuma is trying to help
them.
So instead of absolutely losing their minds
as Kuma sent each member away, they might
be more willing to go along with what Kuma
was doing.
However, that’s just the start of the insanity
because now things are really going to heat
up for Revolutionary Luffy.
Because at this point I think Kuma would change
where he sends Luffy.
And instead of landing on Amazon Lily, Luffy
instead lands where he grew up at the Revolutionary
Army base.
That is of course assuming that Kuma knows
where the current base was on Baltigo, but
let’s imagine that he does.
So Luffy crash lands on his father’s doorstep,
which of course he probably would not like
at all.
But more importantly, he will soon learn about
a major world that is going to change everything.
That’s because it is at this time that news
spreads about Ace’s capture and execution
date.
And even though Luffy didn’t grow up with
Ace, Sabo did for much of his childhood, and
I think both of them would absolutely want
to free Ace.
Which means that the Revolutionaries are going
to suit up for battle.
And while Dragon would probably think an assault
on Impel down is too risky, I could see them
joining the chaotic war at Marineford.
So get ready because Luffy AND Sabo are about
to crash this massive party.
And while it might be simply awesome for Dragon
to also show up, I think he might take advantage
of the distraction to sneak into Impel Down
himself and free his second in command, Ivankov.
But back to the war.
So with Luffy and Sabo here to fight, they
quickly team up with the Whitebeard allies
to try to free Ace.
And while I don’t really think the Revolutionaries
would send their entire army, as long as they
have a small enough squad of powerful fighters
like the Revolutionary Army Commanders they
should make a big impact on the battle.
In fact, Belo Betty’s powers might be perfect
for an all out war like this, since she can
encourage their allies to fight even harder
with her devil fruit.
Plus with this upgraded version of Luffy and
an equally powerful Sabo, I really think that
they are strong enough to free Ace AND survive.
And since we’re already here, let’s say
Luffy goes way over the top and once again
declares war on the world government, but
this time he says it as a Revolutionary and
even plants a revolutionary flag in front
of the entire marine forces.
Which is going to change EVERYTHING.
That’s right, it’s time for Luffy to rejoin
the Revolutionary Army.
Because with everything that Luffy has seen
and experienced up to this point, I think
it is reasonable to think he would fully commit
to taking down the world nobles.
Which means goodbye to the pirate adventures
for now, but this Luffy would likely care
way more about freeing all the oppressed people
in the world, so this change makes sense to
me.
That means Luffy and Sabo will be permanently
reunited, although I’m not sure if Luffy
would be second-in-command and bump Sabo down
or if they would be like co-second in commands
or something.
But the important thing is Luffy is back with
the Revolutionaries, which was the whole point
of this video.
That also means that the straw hats will be
joining up as well, and it is honestly nuts
to think how perfectly each of the straw hats'
dreams still can be reached once they become
revolutionaries.
Nami can still travel and make her maps, plus
the revolutionaries probably even have their
own secret maps that she would love to explore.
There are still tons of strong enemies to
fight for Zoro to grow as a swordsman.
Robin already had ties with the Revolutionaries.
Chopper can still study medicine.
And so on.
As for Ace, I think he’d probably want to
stick with the Whitebeard pirates, especially
if we assume that the former Emperor still
died during the battle.
But even without Ace, the Revolutionaries
just got a massive power boost.
Because after some time training for the Straw
Hats to get stronger, we can easily say that
Luffy is one of the top two or three fighters
in the organization.
Zoro and Sanji are probably top six or seven,
and the rest of the crew are huge additions
to the overall strength of the entire Army.
And with this added power, I could even see
the Revoiutionaries step up their mission
to take down the Celestial Dragons AND free
oppressed countries.
In fact, the crew might even still visit many
of the same islands.
For example, fishman island was about to be
taken over by this evil fishman, so they could
use someone to save them.
Dressrosa was oppressed by Doflamingo.
Wano had literally become a wasteland under
the Emperor Kaido, so I could easily see Luffy
and the Revolutionaries still going to these
places to free more countries and gain more
allies, even though Luffy wouldn’t have
direct ties with characters like Law and Momonoske
at this point.
But in the end it would be just so fitting
if Luffy still unlocks Gear 5 and his advanced
haki during the fight with Kaido, since he
is a true symbol of freedom and liberation.
But all of this is leading up to the undeniable
future clash with the marines and world government.
And while we are still waiting to see how
that would go, I can just imagine with all
the allies of the Revolutionaires, plus a
fully awakened Luffy and the crew, that they
would be able to take down the World Government
and free the world.
However, that does actually leave one major
problem.
Because fighting the marines would put them
directly against family and friends such as
Garp and Luffy’s old friend Koby, who are
both going to be incredibly powerful characters
at this point.
I mean Koby went from this wimpy kid to being
an absolute chad.
And now that I’m thinking about it, I wonder
what would have happened if instead of Luffy
training with his dad, he actually followed
his Grandpa’s wish to become a marine.
So if you want to see exactly how that would
turn out, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.